Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce, this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people.
This is BiDipi.
Build It.
Mike Ando built a real Myst book.
This replica linking book from the video game
Myst has a full desktop computer self-contained
without any external wires or hardware.
It's a project six year in the making and
it contains a copy of all of the the Myst
games which you can play with the touchscreen.
Check out his website for more information.
Jeremy Telford of Balloon Guy Entertainment
built Bag End out of balloons.
The iconic Shire home of Bilbo Baggins took
Telford forty hours to create and includes
a balloon fireplace, chairs, table, and a
hanging candelabra all made up of a total
of 2,600 balloons.
Martian Glass Works is the stained glass work
of Evan Daniels - who creates video game and
comic book inspired pieces.
This Iron Man 3 stained glass in particular
took over 100 hours to construct and uses
334 pieces and 11 different colors of glass.
Check out his Etsy store where he recently
sold this 6.8 square foot Mega Man X panel.
Meanwhile in Tennessee a group founded by
Chris Lee is building a full-scale Millennium
Falcon.
The 1:1 scaled Star Wars prop is a fan project
without a time frame because they really have
no idea how long it will take the 114 long
and 30 foot high ship.
FullScaleFalcon.com has details including
reference material, build updates and more.
Draw It
These 3D optical illusion drawings were created
with an airbrush by Ramon Bruin.
Although he studied at the airbrush academy
in the netherlands the artist says he's mostly
self-taught and loves airbushing because it
allows for photorealistic paintings and designs
on almost any surface.
Chris Scalf is an incredible artist mostly
specializing in science fiction and fantasy.
He has a bunch of great Star Wars art on his
deviant art page and a series of photo realism
on his website.
Check out his YouTube page which includes
not only time lapse videos but also a dragon
digital painting in real-time.
And now some works from POP2: The Art Of Pop
Culture Returns at Ltd.
Art Gallery...
Peruvian Illustrator Guillermo Fajardo created
some re-imagined cereal box art including
legendary breakfast mascots like Tony The
Tiger and Count Chocula.
Play It
Jon Gomm is an english guitar player that
combines drum bass and melody parts at the
same time - here here's his cover of Message
In A Bottle by the Police...
Dyskograf is a concept by Jesse Lucas that
allows pen on a paper record to be interpreted
by a camera and played like a record...
SaReGaMa makes homemade instruments including
this 7-tines kalimba assembled from discarded
materials...
Finally the video for SOHN's The Wheel utilizes
footage from the prelinger archives that juxtaposes
nature and industry....
Submit your own bidipis as a personal message
here on youtube.
Or share them with everyone over at facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always... thanks for watching.